[Music]
all right let's go out to Harrisburg and
talk to relle what up
relle what is up Dr John what's up how
we
doing I'm doing well how are you just I
mean if I had more fun I'd probably
asleep I don't that means but hey so
what's what's going on how can I help
yeah so thanks so much for taking my
call uh my question for you is how can I
stop obsessing over my weight loss
journey and learn to love the body that
I'm in oh man tell me about
it yeah so I'm 33 I'm a stay home to two
little boys who are both allergic to
sleep
so I don't have a lot of time and when I
do have time I'm usually pretty tired um
but kind of my history like I've always
been a big girl um not always like I
mean always chubby but I'm tall just
never been one of those cute petite
little things um always struggled with
body dysmorphia and still do um did all
the things in adolescence and even in
early adulthood as far as diet you know
the Weight Watchers The Slim Fast all
the things it wasn't really until the
last five to seven years that I really
got on track and started looking at my
health and what I would consider a
healthy way it's really I love mind pump
the Mind pump guys and Dr Lane Norton
it's you and those two podcasts on
constant repeat over here are great guys
yeah yeah so um like I said I have two
little boys worked really really hard to
have healthy pregnancies with them um
just kept walking kept strength training
the first one I lost all of the M weight
immediately I was really blessed with a
healthy pregnancy that I was able to
keep up with that I know not that's not
the situation for all women but luckily
it was for me that time um and also at
the second one again really tried to to
not gain a a ton of weight tried to g a
healthy amount of weight working with my
doctors to keep that a healthy pregnancy
as well um but after my second baby as I
continued to breastfeed every single
pound that I had lost came back so uh
that little boy just turned two and I'm
currently sitting at right now the same
weight that I did when I walked in with
an almost 8B baby in my belly okay um I
just found myself when I have to go
places with my family and you know we
have to get dressed up uh which for me
is anything but leggings I find myself
cranky because I'm wearing clothes in
sizes I've never worn before um and it's
just it's really affecting all facets of
my life because I am so discontent with
my current body
yeah dude thanks for saying that out
loud I know that's not fun to say out
loud huh yeah it's
embarrassing I have this like beautiful
specimen of a husband who can like eat
an entire sleeve of Oreos and maintain a
sixpack which is super annoying it'll
get him it'll catch him it will catch
him just wait it'll just one day he'll
it'll it'll get him
um did you grow up in a house where
um people watch what you
ate uh yeah yeah so that's wired into to
you
mhm the um oh honey that shirt makes you
look pudgy let's wear the other
shirt yeah yeah it wasn't necessarily
even comments towards me but very much
comments about themselves there you go
and um yeah never yeah luckily nothing
ever pointed towards me but just hearing
this the negative self talk yeah yeah
and their negative selft talk became
what you saw in the world and then what
you saw in the world became your
negative selft talk about other people
and then that became the story you tell
about
yourself um yeah what' your husband say
about all
this um he is incredibly encouraging um
he OB you know he he acknowledges uh you
know that obviously I have gained weight
because you know it's a lot of times all
I can talk about um he still makes me
feel loved and attractive to the best of
his ability but obviously if it's not
something like he can only do so much
with his words and his actions and I
think and he kind of gets frustrated
sometimes um as I as I think anyone
would to I mean it's this Obsession for
me that I'm just I it's always this well
I'll be happier when I've lost the
weight when I can fit into the old genes
when I can walk next to you and feel
like proud to you know be your
wife how have you equated
that how you've
equated a number on a scale and with the
size of your pants
with then he'll love
me and you're describing ways when he's
like getting frustrated because he's
watching the woman that he loves and
that he's sexually attracted to and that
he is like seeing being an amazing mom
of his two
kids
um his frustration is that she can't see
how
much he loves
her
yeah where's that story come
from cuz it's not true I yeah I don't um
but you you've equate you've equated
like weight loss with
value yeah um I think what's just so
frustrating for me is I feel like I'm
putting in the
work you know I'm watching what I eat
and I'm working out
and I it's not
working and hold on I you how old are
your
kids uh just turn two and just turn four
okay so you're living inside of a
blender without a top on
it and you're
exhausted and did you have a picture of
what let's put weight aside because I
think that's
symptomatic did you think being a mom
was going to feel different than this
yeah I I really struggled um with
postpartum depression yeah with both of
them and I also struggled with a lot of
infertility before them and it's real
easy when you struggle with infertility
you struggle with
postpartum that these kids this family
is going to rescue me it's going to feel
like I'm finally
here very similar to the way sometimes
and again I'm over genderize this but
the way a man says man when I finally
make six figures when I finally get
$100,000 a year then I'll fill in the
blank and part of that compounding
challenge is you're holding your baby
and you and your hormones are all over
the place and you're sitting there in
this postpartum Funk and you start to
think a good mom wouldn't feel like this
a good mom who'd struggle with
infertility and holding her baby would
should be grateful and should be feeling
like this and I
don't so yet again there's another notch
in the there's something not right about
me I've never been cute and petite I
married a smoke show I've never been
this my parents weren't enough I'm not
this and it should be feeling like this
so let's have another kid we just need
to have a
family and all of a sudden you're
sitting in the reality four-year-olds
are insane they're literally insane they
are weed eaters with ears and eyes and
then you have a 2-year-old that's in
that Gap I call it like the fourth the
fourth dimension of hell where they're
kind of human but also kind of not right
they're like humans but you kind of
still change diapers are kind of like
Mom I pooped ah and then can I have a
snack can I have a snack can I have a
snack can I have a
snack and it was all supposed to feel
different yeah yeah I had this picture
in my mind that I would you know be
taking my babies on walks and and I
think because I thought I struggled so
much to get pregnant with
them that I would be exempt from all the
postpartum stuff yeah because I I
struggled so
much and I think you don't that
shouldn't happen yeah yeah and so
I I I say something weird okay do you
probably have weight to lose yeah I I
believe you yeah I believe you no
question
um does your husband love you yeah I
believe you on that
too did your those crazy little boys win
the lottery getting you as their mama
yeah I believe
that I also am going to challenge
you this story has to stop with
you the story that you picked up from
your parents and the story that they
picked up from their
parents that I'll be worth loving I'll
be worth being proud of when fill in the
blank that has to stop with you because
those little boys will pick that up
too is that fair and I feel like I'm I
feel like I'm already noticing it where
I notice my four-year-old coming up and
saying mommy I did this are you proud of
me yeah and I tell him I'm proud of you
no matter what you know even if you
didn't do that I'm proud of you but I
noticed okay I'm going to tell I'm going
to tell you something hard and I I
hesitate to tell moms this because I
don't want you to internalize this and
make this about fault I want you to make
this about opportunity do you promise
you can do that if I tell you this I I
can yeah your little
boy has a radar that he's scanning the
environment all the time to make sure
he's
safe and he feels mom's not
okay and when he asks you are you proud
of me do you see me what he's asking is
am I helping you feel
okay yeah he's trying to heal the
tension in his
environment and I say this with all love
in my heart for you my friend that's not
his job that's your job absolutely and
so I want you to not look at this as a
weight loss win or loss or a weight loss
failure or a I've always been a big girl
now I'm just the thing is happening to
me that I swore wouldn't happen which is
I'm going to become one of those ladies
that just lets himself go that's not the
conversation we'll get
there the conversation is I thought my
life was going to feel different than it
does right now and I thought it was
going to look different I thought my
experience of two healthy beautiful
little baby boys in a smoke show husband
was going to heal this inner child this
kid that I've never really liked she's
never been pretty enough she's never
been cute she's never been petite she's
never been those
girls and I thought these external
things would do it and it's
not that's the place you have to go
to and as a guy who struggle with body
dysmorphia I am telling you it wasn't
until and you've heard me do it on the
show I it wasn't until my councelor
caught
me she was like uh she golf clapped me
and she was like oh you're real smart
and you have lots of words
congratulations you're smart and then
that's when she made me make a fist and
put it in my chest and say the words I
love this this guy and I couldn't make
those words come out of my mouth and she
smiled and she goes there it
is you can have the perfect workout
program the perfect exercise program the
perfect ACT or DBT or rebt the perfect
therapeutic
modality but if at the end of the day
you don't look in the mirror and like
who you
see all of it is going to be a roller
coaster pingpong match for the rest of
your
life
and so I think the work here is we'll
get to the I I trust that you're
disciplined my gosh and I trust you can
quote unquote lose you know the calories
and I trust that you can exercise I
don't think that's your challenge right
now I think your body is still rattling
like a snow globe because you don't like
you tell me if I'm
wrong no I I don't think I could do that
I don't you know when I'm
even like getting you know dressed for
the day and I look in the mirror I'm
like I can't think this body that I
prayed for so long would give me these
children that are just such blessings I
even can't find myself to like thank God
and thank my body for doing that because
there's just nothing I look in the
mirror that I like there you
go will you make me a promise that
you'll call somebody a professional and
sit down and say those exact words you
just said to me
yeah I'm I'm already on the schedule I
just can't get in until next month but
it's already in the works
okay I want you to go sit down in front
of that person who you see and if when
you walk in if your shoulders don't drop
immediately I want you to just leave
well you've waited a long time so go
ahead and have the first
session but you'll need somebody not to
over clinical IE you you're going to
need somebody that sees
you CU what your body needs right now is
not more information and your body needs
someone to look at you and say I love
you just cuz you walked in the door and
I'm so glad you're here because you
don't do that for
you and this sounds bananas but the
single greatest gift you can give that
husband of yours who's awesome those
kids of yours that are awesome is a mom
and a
wife that is really um proud to be
her and that sounds like a thousand
miles away that sounds like making fun
of you right doesn't it sounds so
ridiculous to say that it it makes it a
different I mean changing the
perspective about it being about my boys
and about my marriage rather than just
me but it seems like it's a goal I want
to get there but I have absolutely no
idea how to get there here's how you do
it you sit down in front of somebody
face to face and say the exact same
things you just said to
me I've got everything everything I ever
want
wanted and when I'm getting dressed in
the morning I stop and I look at myself
before I'm dressed and I drop my
shoulders and I'm
sad because I don't not only do I not
like what I see I don't like the person
I
see and I want to love
me I want you to start there with your
counselor my promise is there's healing
up on the other side of that and then
that little four-year-old little boy is
not going to be trying to make mom feel
better about mom because he loves you
more than life itself and that husband
of yours just looks over and sees
beautiful
you and he hates the fact that somebody
hates the woman he loves so much it just
happens to be you I'm proud of you so
proud of you today is day
one and keep listening to mind pump guys
into to Lane my buddy Jordan scatt keep
listening to those
guys they'll give you the the
tools but all that stuff is symptom
let's go beneath it let's go sit down
with somebody and say I want to learn to
love me it's time I want to love me as
much as my little boys do it's a good
place to start I'm proud
you